this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised this is why the inclu McBride is
such a firm favorite
[Music]
it just looks ready for a fight this is
still her territory good afternoon and
welcome to the fourteenth episode of
Safari lives a highlights package of the
week's goings on
from here on the western fringes of the
great Kruger National Park and of course
up in the Maasai Mara in the Mara
triangle my name is James Henry on
camera today we've got sins or Kizer
all the way from kwazulu-natal and up in
the Mara we have the inimitable couple
of Brent and Jamie Leo Smith Patterson
or Patterson Leo Smith I'm not sure what
they're known as anymore these days
they'll be keeping you updated with all
the goings on with waffles and the Mara
were bottles in the North Clan and of
course all of the lion prides a sausage
tree pride the ala Lulu pry the Paradise
pride and all the magnificent animals of
the migration we are trying to head
towards the character we haven't seen
for some time and that is the Evo cos we
did not see the Evo cos this week we did
see quite a lot of leopards
at Juma it's been mostly a leopard week
as usual husana are two and a half year
old Prince spend time close to camp as
he has done for the past two months but
he's starting to range much more widely
now he ate a duiker
possibly stolen from tandy south of our
boundary two days ago we've had limited
time with 10 Ghana he killed in Yala
near the eastern boundary had his prize
pinched and then disappeared into
Torchwood
Tandy spent most of the week around
treehouse dam where we think she had a
kill much of her time was occupied with
calling for her accustomed otter Columba
the princess's playful tracks were all
we found of her on the lion front we had
a very special time with the humans on
foot treehouse damn one morning their
faces were covered in blood but we
failed to find their victim
[Music]
up north in the mara triangle the
sausage tree pride hunted the herds as
did any self-respecting lion pride the
Ala Lola's and Paradise prides included
the North clan continued to amaze with
waffles and her Cubs so that's what
we're going to be focusing on this
afternoon don't worry Brent and Jamie
have not got made and not told you about
it now I was just being relatively
playful I suppose so please don't worry
about that as always you are the most
important character in all of our safari
life so please talk to us using the hash
tags fire live on Twitter otherwise the
chat stream on YouTube the characters of
which I spoke are the Avoca males the
Avoca males came down south yesterday
apparently no sorry not yesterday this
afternoon and they killed a water buck
somewhere around here there are a great
heap of vultures there is a great heap
of vultures on a dead tree over there
under it is quite possibly the carcass
of a hapless water buck bull and we'll
go and see if we can't reunite with the
Avoca males which will be very exciting
indeed while we head there we are going
to go back up to the Maasai Mara
where the Predators are enjoying the
smorgasbord of the migration rent Leo
Smith who uses words like smorgasbord a
lot is waiting to greet you welcome to
the Masai Mara in Kenya and as you can
see we have a slightly disturbing sight
there is blood all over the back legs of
that poor zebra and has obviously made
it across the Mara River but not without
massive injury and of course that leaves
it vulnerable to not only the north clan
but the Musketeers and the Paradise
pride my name is Brent Dara Smith I have
Archaea on camera with me and I hope
you're ready for this edition of safari
light as you can figure since I'm with a
wounded zebra I must be quite close to
the crossings and indeed I am there is a
buildup of zebra at Maine North however
our Chi and I think we know more than
the others there and we think they're
gonna cross it Maine south shame poor
zebra let's hope a predator does find
soon and put it out of its misery it is
quite badly wounded and I don't think
with that injury and the density of
predators that we have here in the Masai
Mara that that zebra will last too long
of course if you have any questions
hashtag a safari live is the best way to
get hold of us and I'm just gonna try
get your view of the Zebras we've been
watching and one has to be quite clever
when you're around the crossings because
it's often a lot of vehicle build-up
especially since there haven't been many
crossings this year but Archie is
probably the crossing king off to doing
all the crossings with Taylor earlier
this year and archana an agreement that
they're gonna walk to main north they're
gonna have a squiz and then I think
nananananana this is a bad idea and then
I come across down here at main south so
hopefully we don't get it wrong but
fortunately if we do that we've got a
long camera lens to compensate for our
bad judgement but we think the zebras
are going to move from that particular
point off main north and come back yeah
well let's show you the zebras quickly
and who knows my favorite nude little
friends the banded mongoose family that
sleep here at Maine South might come for
a visit so that's there we go see how
any pocket dillion's down here as well
but we can see the Zebras waiting on the
northern bank of the Mara River and
we're gonna do some patience as you can
see it doesn't look like they want to
cross there I think they're gonna come
cross down here at Maine South and the
problem with Maine South is there are
some seriously big crocodiles in wait
there waiting and that's probably
exactly what caught that poor little
zebra there we go there is the apex
aquatic predator of the Maasai Mara now
it sounds like Jaime has already found
the apex land predator of the Maasai
Mara
let's go have a look we are not a far
away from Brent at all and we are not
with the animal that we expected to be
with her this afternoon but that's just
the way things go out here in the Masai
Mara and indeed the African wilderness
in general a very good afternoon to you
all and welcome to this episode of
safari lives it's wonderful to have you
onboard don't forget to send through
your questions in the normal ways and
let me explain exactly what it is that
is going on over here so these two boys
and until we can confirm exactly who
they are let's call them the nomads they
have burst onto the scene over the last
few days Brent had them chasing a male
lion back south and then they vanished
for a few days but during that whole
event rains noticed that one of them was
missing the tip of his tail and quite a
recent injury as well and we didn't see
them for a few days and in a way thought
nothing of it because they're still
quite young and the Musketeers are still
dominated most of this area scar the
line that a Brent was talking about
earlier but then on my way towards a
North clan's in sight lo and behold who
should be lying under a tree less than
about a hundred yards or so from the den
itself were the two boys they are still
less than about a hundred yards or so
from the den now this morning we
encountered one very anxious looking
waffles after she heard the sound of
these males roaring she kind of wanted
to go to the den she was looking in the
direction of the den but she didn't dare
put herself or her babies at risk by
approaching it at what this means their
continued presence here is that waffles
has not been back to her cubs the entire
day she went off and lay down in a
natural plunge pool in a swampy bit of
this area I don't know I suspect that
she is
probably stole there but I can't go and
check because I don't know exactly where
she is
so once again patience always pays off
we're going to stick it out with these
boys and keep checking back in on
waffles is dead to see if she does get
to feed her cubs tonight all these lines
haven't eaten and neither have waffles
as Cubs but the Evoque has certainly
have yes they have and they're keeping
these birds off their kill I've just
heard that in parently is not their kill
and in the fine tradition of male lions
all over the world they have pilfered it
from the Inca home of pride so the three
Avoca males who have taken this
territory without so much as a scratch
to their faces now are taking kills from
the Inca home of pride who seem to be
much more comfortably moving up north
into the Avoca domain and as I have
mentioned before they spent quite a lot
of time down south while amber eyes had
her cubs because they were almost
certainly sired by one of the birmingham
boys and then she lost those two hyenas
and since then the pride has moved
closer and closer into the ambit of the
Avoca boys because they will most likely
in fact almost certainly be the males
that now dominate the Inca Verma pride
the pride clearly has not decided that
they like the Evoque is very much yet
and have absconded after their meal was
stolen from them now if you haven't met
the Avoca boys before well this is them
and from their looks I'd say they're
probably about four years old now and
pretty early on for them to have taken a
territory and when I say they came in
here and took a territory without so
much as receiving a scratch to the face
I say that because their arrival here
was beautifully timed I don't think they
did that on purpose I think it was
entirely lucky but they arrived here
just as the birmingham boys erstwhile
owners of these lands headed down south
to fill of a
can see on the Sand River which was
brought about by the demise of the
merging gallon coalition and said that
birmingham's moved south and these young
what I call them hipsters millennial
hipsters moved in and well they haven't
had to fight for their land at all
they've just kind of set up started
roaring nobody came to chase them away
and so they thought well we'll just hang
about and state they have been seen
mating with a pride called the talimar T
pride but as yet we are unaware of them
trying to sire any Cubs with the Inca
homers which of course are our favorite
lines they're the ones that we see the
most often
I agree Ravinder absolutely so it's nice
to have males back in the reserve it's
really great to have male lions back in
the reserve especially three chaps like
this it's hope they hang around for a
while there's no reason they shouldn't
they're big and strong and young and
unless a coalition of say I don't know
six year olds comes into this area from
where I I don't know they're in probably
for a fairly long haul here and the
other thing to say about this of course
is that this was a water buck and water
Bucks are legendarily not eaten by lions
of course that is nonsense
here are some lions eating water buck
Brent Lea Smith has not managed to find
any lions just yet I've no doubt he will
during the course of the next two hours
he has managed to find something else
though this time it's a bird the birds
just keep disappearing there we go a
dark cat ballou
at least it didn't leave us like the
others that were here a little bit
earlier now the Zebras have started
moving away from main north so and so I
think I'll gamble to come down to main
south was it not a bad one and also we
don't get to be surrounded by four here
calls
and I might go for a little wonder
though and see if we can find some lines
around yet I'm keeping an eye on the
wounded zebra is it gone no it was just
over here you see it no it's around this
and we haven't have a look now but in
the meantime there's been some very
interesting developments in the lion
prides in Namara this year the
migrations been late there's been a lack
of food up in the northern part which is
caused one of the prides of lions we got
to know very very well last year that
all Olalla pride to head down south onto
the Bern into what was the core of the
sausage tree pride territory three
members of the oh la la la pride seemed
to have moved into what was
traditionally sausage tree pride
territory enjoying the short green grass
of the Bern and taking an advantage of
the animals attracted to the area they
seemed very comfortable in their new
surrounds playing and grooming and they
are not going anywhere for now look at
that absolute monster it could even have
been the one that was responsible for
that nasty wound on the zebra that is a
very big croc probably four meters in
length and weighing six seven hundred
kilograms isn't that impressive what a
massive animal there's a smaller one
coming downstream
and the most productive crossing areas
here in the deep water have the biggest
crocodiles and the big males will
actually chase off other big males from
these areas to ensure that they always
get the best and biggest me all the ones
getting up on the other side not as big
but still moving into the water can they
sense that the Zebras are coming
don't dun dun they're just absolutely
fascinating creatures I know crocodiles
a lot of people don't like them they're
considered quite evil and nasty but they
have regenerative qualities so the the
oil in fat from a crocodile has been
used traditionally to treat wounds and
and and scars and they actually do you
have really true genitive properties
that they can they recover from injuries
very quickly and they can recover from
the nastiest injuries possible and they
can do it quite quickly with it's almost
incredible how fast they can oh is that
what I think it is
Archie on the opposite bank just below
the cars it is not what I thought it was
and it is a stick don't worry we will
leave that at that I'll just keep quiet
and pretend and not even tell you what I
thought it was and it's always pays to
check yeah I said we're gonna spend a
little bit more time here at the river
with the monsters of the Mara and see if
the Zebras decide to brave it before
Last Light the meantime James is with
the new kings of the northern sabi sands
well yes I suppose you might describe
them as the new Kings I'm going to
sneeze everybody I do apologize
somebody's got my nose I think it's some
dust who anyway there are the new Kings
eating away now we haven't seen much in
the way of lions this week we did have
one wonderful sighting of the Inca
Hula's of course on foot and that was
tremendously special wild painted is
that your name wild painted the Inca not
think of him as the Evoque has arrived
apparently sometime this morning this
went down last night sometime and the
Evoque has arrived to lift it from its
erstwhile owner's sometime during the
course of this morning you can see that
they have been eating for some time and
you can tell that from the one that you
the one you can see at the back there
just from the way that he's obviously
breathing so heavily yes Joshua we too
have missed the Avoca boys and very
pleased to have them back with us here
then of course they're not the only
predators out here or meat eaters if we
look around in the skies when the trees
there are a lot of vultures and the
closest vulture is a hooded vulture and
you can see that they are well if you
can imagine the playground at school and
the little fellow who was always the
butt of the jokes always being beaten up
by everyone else and when the bullies
set upon the slightly smaller boys those
slightly smaller boys were then set upon
the really small boys and that is what
you're looking at there the hooded
vulture is the bottom end of vulture
Society and although it might be sitting
there thinking I'm quite brave sitting
close to the Lions assumes the Lions
depart the big white back vultures all
around
going to come in and chase away the
hooded vulture and the hooded vultures
got that hooked small beak because it
can then take advantage of the bits of
meat that the bigger beaked white backed
vultures are unable to but they will
have to wait until the white backs are
done we'll be very careful lest they get
picked then sends all just to the right
of that there is a fight back Vol'jin
you can actually see it right back which
is quite unusual very nice now I'm sure
a lot of you who've never seen a picture
of the back end of a white vector
vulture must be wondering why on earth
they called white back falters well that
is why you saw that fight back and
apparently that it allows them to follow
each other two kills it reflects the Sun
very nicely I think that's quite a good
explanation for why it's there I can't
imagine another one why she lets go back
to the Lions now it's very nice to
actually have them doing something
pervert yes I suppose at some time we
will give the Evoque a--'s names now
they don't have any names at the moment
I'm not sure what that water bucks name
was you can see his face now he is
obviously late as they say in this part
of the world he's no longer with us
the Evo cos I suppose we'll probably
name when we see them slightly more
frequently at the moment who talked
about this before didn't we we decided
we should name them after different
varietals of avocados because of course
Avoca is his French for avocado and I
think we came up with some wonderful
varietals ones that I had never heard of
before
that's right Pinkle tonight Hass
Pinkerton Hass and I'm not sure what the
other one was there was an almost
shutdown of the Twitter servers when we
suggested this because people were
deeply distressed that we were thinking
about naming lions after avocado
varietals and that of course caused
those who were suggesting it to tease
those who didn't like it even further
causing a further meltdown of the
internet Pinkerton wakka moly and hast I
think is what we decided don't worry
there's not official names everybody
will no doubt give them local names
locally relevant names at some stage now
Jamie had a very interesting situation
this morning where waffles as Cubs were
being all certainly heard inside was
being investigated by two interloping
male lions let's go and find out what
they're doing now I did indeed and I'm
really hoping that a for my last a drive
in the Mara we get it to see waffles and
her cupboard before it's time for me to
head back into camp
James as usual displaying his enormous
Lea and what we normal n't I mean it
comes to naming animals I think we'll
have to keep him well away from these
two boys what do you think boys lest he
cause more disruption on the internet I
think we'll wait just a little bit
longer to see if we can figure out
exactly where it is these boys come from
who they are and what exactly their
background is and that could take quite
a while they're quite distinctive boy as
though we can't really count the missing
tail tip because that's a really to be
recent injury but the nicks out of their
ears and their whisker spots are very
clear hopefully we should be able to
figure out okay wait I don't want to
sorry cursed I don't want to I didn't
quite hear you but I think what I'm
going to have to do is send you back
across to Juma because something
interesting is playing out with the
Lions there now very interestingly
something has arrived here in fact have
probably been there all day long I
thought it was a little bit strange when
we got here that the Inka homers weren't
around but there they are they're
actually just popped their heads up out
of the shade and we'll go and have a
look at them shortly sins all spotted
them with his fantastic eyes and this is
very interesting of course because it
means that they weren't chased off the
kill and put to flight they were chased
off the kill certainly but they have
remained around these male lions so
they're obviously no longer feel any
kind of threat for them but let's go and
see perhaps if there aren't more than we
can see there and maybe the entire pride
of 11 is that was
that's very exciting
Nikita I'm not sure what the figures
would be and how you would compare what
the figures were with anything that you
might have a reference for but the great
legend is that a lion is powerful enough
to slap a man's head clean off his
shoulders so if he was to take a full
swipe and cuff you around the sort of
jaw and ear area your head would come
clean off your shoulders so I mean
whether that's true or not I'm not sure
I'm not sure how many people have
actually tested it but they are
immensely powerful we I think we as
human beings really don't have a very
good understanding of just how feeble we
are as physical specimens now it's a
slender mongoose knocking about here as
well that's good
one lioness in front of us
you can see some others can you sense
all one walking away and one here well
here are two of them let me just go
around this way
she's looking up towards the north-south
sorry
so there we go yes Cal six you'd think
so wouldn't you 11 versus three doesn't
seem like very good odds a male lion
however is designed to fight that is
what they're designed to do and not
necessarily with females but normally
with other males in order to protect
their territories and so you will find
that yeah even eleven lionesses are
going to struggle to put three males to
flight also remember that of the eleven
six of them are sub-adults which means
they will be very reticent to tangle
physically with male lions now I think
she's looking up towards the wrist of
the pride well she's not she's just
having it yawn but the other one I think
is looking up towards the wrist the
pride so I think maybe we should go and
have a look and see if we can't find him
we'll just drive up the scaring path and
I can see some Lion tracks on it they're
coming this way though so I think they
would this these chaps oops
drove into a small tree behind us since
all made a sort of striped grunting
noise I wasn't really sure what he meant
it's just quickly see she's looking
straight up in this direction it might
be at the vultures but it might be at
the rest of the pride nasty chilly
breeze coming out of the southeast
starlings gonna be quite cold once the
Sun does go down it's a fantastic way to
start our afternoon she's looking at
some Impaler actually I can see some
Impala and zebras but I don't see the
wrist of the pride they've come all the
way along this game path here which
leads directly to a pan in some Bambi
Lee called one-eyed pan and I wonder if
that's not where the wrister pride out
we'll do a quick loop around there while
you go back to the Maasai Mara to Brent
who is going to use alliteration to
describe the river that is the Mara in
which things die well as you know when
you're live out in the African bush
anything can happen at any moment and
while we were passionately sitting for
some zebras to possibly leap into the
murderous Mara River a herd of
wildebeest came rushing down from the
opposite bank and it looked like they
were going to plunge immediately towards
the waiting death of the Nile crocodile
but unfortunately well they sort of
stopped him having a bit of a team talk
I would before I swam across the stretch
to the river this monster male croc is
still right next to us at the moment
they say where is it good he weighs
probably a good six seven hundred
kilograms about four meters in length
this is the first full beast in in in a
long time we've seen on the opposite
side of the river
Sam's wondering have we seen any kills
made by the Crocs this week do the first
this week or last week we saw one zebra
that was killed by quite a big crocodile
and is a very small cross
so the youths crocodiles have had a
quite tough this year they've been very
very few crossings in the in the
northern part of the Mara most of the
crossings have happened at the steep
Bank crossings down south where there
are very few crocodiles and they're a
bit hungry this year they might have to
top-up on catfish for the rest of the
year because the beasts are probably not
gonna be around for too much longer the
zebra will as they know me the first
across they'll also cross for a little
bit longer but it looks like these Valle
de beast might have changed their mind
and might actually head down towards
dusty crossing or they might just stay
on that side of the river for tonight
who knows what goes through a little
beasts brain not me that's for certain
Oh Archer right up ahead of us in had
Maine North is a hippo fighter going on
far in the distance over to the left
look quite serious for a second it you
can see that male flicking its tail and
awful ooh that snort so obviously a
territorial male trying to defend he is
a group of females from an interloper or
possibly even a young male that he's
pushing out of the raft of hippopotamus
looks like it's calmed down a little bit
there is our bill these are moving
orphan but there is a zebra coming up to
the crossing
so maybe the zebras might take the
chance and all it does is take one heads
up
I think
we should just stick around yeah a
little bit I think these Evers let's
give them a second or two see what they
do if they stay standing there is more
zebras coming in as well I think they
might need a bit of time to build some
courage so I'm gonna sit right yeah in
the meantime let's send you across to
Jamie oh no we're not going to Jamie's
perhaps we we're gonna stick with us
Joshua wants to know if he pose ever go
after animals crossing the Mara River
sometimes they do and are very
unpredictable sometimes they might save
an animal from the crocodiles other
times they might actually feed off that
animal themselves I've seen hippo feed
on wildebeest I've seen and feed on
giraffe I've seen them feed on other
hippos it is quite rare normally they
are obviously herbivores but
occasionally they do eat meat an
occasion they might just kill it one of
the passing animals for no reason in
particular apart from the fact that they
are annoyed that they are close to them
some of these Crocs seem to have picked
up that there's animals around because
they're starting to move sort of right
into the spot where their animals across
okay well I think I don't things gonna
happen just yet so we're gonna keep our
patient pants on sit right here
in the meantime let's send you across to
Jamie with some sleepy lions so while
Brent keeps his patience pants on for
which we are all eternally grateful
the indecisiveness of the wildebeest has
truly worked in the animals favour out
here look at the battle scars on these
young lions war wounds at a young age as
I assume they are seeking to establish
themselves in this area that's what
seems to be the case it spells bad news
for some of the lion prides around here
as a territorial takeover always done
in the initial periods of its beginnings
just the same with the evoke occurs and
the Inka homers but for the hyenas of
North gland they are quite used to lions
wandering around I'm not too concerned
about waffles but we'll have to wait and
see how that plays out this afternoon
however the hyenas are far more
concerned with a taking advantage of
both the arrival of the migration and
the stormy weather we've experienced the
localized yet heavy rains that we have
been experiencing in the Mara have
transformed north clan land back into
its usual swampy state and the hyena
River under these conditions after a
massive downpour we happened upon Fergus
who was loping over the mushy ground
hunting in the half-hearted manner of a
hyena simply trying his luck with
boundless stamina on his side all Ferg
had to do was run into the scattered
antelope and zebra causing chaos while
looking for a weakness his attention was
diverted by the tantalizing prospect of
an old sinewy carcass not much nutrition
there he was joined by his mother
waffles and began to behave like a small
cup rather than a fully grown male in
his prime
perhaps even hyena revert winning the
company of their parents
waffles waited for her son to lose
interest in the pile of old bones before
the two of them set off on a hunting
mission together just like old times
waffles may have new Cubs but that
doesn't mean that she has forgotten
about her two boys they moved off and
left us in their wake and leave us in
their wake they did because there was
simply no way that we could follow them
over that a wet ground a truly lovely
sight to seed see that a waffles is not
completely distracted by her two new
Cubs and in fact still loves her boys
equally because the time we spent with
her in the past she has always been with
them always following them around and I
can only imagine that they feel a little
bereft our as our lions asleep
peacefully the same cannot be said for
the Lions of Juma know what we've got
here is the lioness of the incomer pride
now staring down the males who have just
become aware of these two lionesses
we've been driving around seeing if the
rest of the pride is here they are not
they seem to be on some Bambi Leah I
think so it's just the two lionesses
here at the moment and those males have
spotted them and they're looking this
way whether they will decide to come up
here and investigate is anyone's guess
it is a cool afternoon only about 23
degrees Celsius or so and so the chances
are quite strong that you know they
could move and come up here and see
what's going on child of the universe I
think it's unlikely that the Inklings
would try and chase off a lone hostile
male
unless of course there were Cubs that
they felt were threatened I have seen
females chase males I've seen them bite
them I mean we have that tremendous
fight with Brent where I think it was
the Birmingham boys two of them started
having a go at each other and then the
females got involved and but them both
so it's not like there won't fight with
males but there'd be very careful of the
misperceive they've got souther lots
with them now one of those males has
started slinking off towards the right
hand side of your picture and the
lioness was very aware of it the other
lioness has also lifted her head now she
was looking a bit sleepy
she's just behind that stick I'm afraid
I can just try and sneak slightly
forward what a nice little standoff
we've got going here and who knows if
this is the first meeting that they've
had yeah Larina good thought you wonder
if this is amber eyes and the youngest
lioness I'm not sure I haven't managed
to see adequately yet
he's fascinated I can't see the other
two I don't know if one of them isn't
coming around the side no there's one to
his left I think I doubt they'll try and
flank these lionesses I think they just
walk straight up to them if they wanted
to really find out what was going on
I see him glancing to his left there are
right the other males coming this way
but like I say these lionesses don't
seem to be particularly distressed
there's definitely one on his right hand
side our left still eating
and back to the food Oh are we
giraffe girl they look like they have
relatively well-fed but this look what a
lot of meat left on that carcass so I
don't know how much of it they ate
they're certainly not full the Inca
humus there may have had a little bit
before they were chased off I suppose
also you know there must still be quite
nervous of the youngsters some of whom
almost two years old and others have
just passed two years old and one of
those of ochres is very interested he's
not interested enough to get up here and
come and say hello what's going on one
wonders if it's just teenage nerves
perhaps he's seen a lady through the
grass and thinking to himself I'd like
to go and say hello but I don't know
what I say you know I mean hi my name is
George or my name's Pinkerton what's
your name you know I mean amber eyes if
that is her as an intimidating lioness
see look he's looking away and I seems
to be slightly shamed the fact that he's
not prepared to come say hello to her
his mates are saying to him come on
fingers off you go say hi you know I'd
like to but everyone even nervous
namaste
I anticipate something if they do meet
up between a fight and a greeting I
don't think that they are well
acquainted enough for it to be a
friendly head rubbing event but I don't
think that the male's would try and tear
the females apart she's still looking
towards them now there could be two
reasons for this one they're hungry
that's the most obvious reason the other
is of course that there's still a
negotiated settlement to be made here
between the Evo cos and the inka Huma
pride when the Birmingham boys came into
this area they started killing
everything they could find and they
murdered a few lionesses here he's
moving now they murdered a few lionesses
in the from the original uncle my pride
and one of them eventually went and made
peace with the Avoca sand we had a
tremendous sighting one evening late one
evening we drove out and there we had
the five Birmingham boys I think it was
that's right and one of the in Kakuma
lionesses and she tried to entice each
of them to mate with her and eventually
one did and quite apart from her
embarrassingly obvious it was that the
male didn't know what he was doing it
was fascinating to see how she was
trying to coax them appease them and
show her acceptance of them quite
possibly for the rest of the pride there
we go
now she's she he's like laying down and
so she's probably quite safe
fantastic stuff all right I think we'll
go and have another look at the mails
now while we go all the way across to
the Masai Mara where Brent Lea Smith
remains on the banks of the great river
itself so while we play the patient's
game down at the edge of the Mara River
we've got a lovely
Ripple's a starling to show you sitting
right next to us
isn't that wonderful even though there's
very little light you can still see
their iridescent coming off his feathers
and the little midges buzzing around his
head now we've had a bit of it
interesting development on the opposite
bank is now that big herd of zebras
which also has come to join the bull the
Beast and they seem to be having a big
chitchat about whether it's going to be
worth their while to brave the river
before sunset
now with the Zebras arriving I think it
actually increases the chance of a
crossing happening what we really need
is some zebras to start preying on the
opposite bank that normally gets them
going properly
just watch carefully
we've got time and the most important
thing when you're out in the African
bush is patience patience patience
okay so while we play the patience game
with all these little zebra fights but a
kick to the face they are quite horrible
to each other but not as horrible as
lions are to them let's go catch up with
allah-allah pride again on their search
for food the hola Lala's
still surrounded by the migration
continued the haphazard hunting style
but with no luck although it seems there
had fed the night before so hunting was
not a serious business before too long
they settle down in the shade of a
gardenia hoping rather that a wildebeest
would come to them well the Zebras seem
to be going one way the bull the Beast
the other it's gonna be interesting to
see what happens here where their move
will they move back up towards the main
north crossing or will zebras heading
down towards main south prompt the
wildebeest to change their mind and join
the masses they try avoid the jaws of
death that live in the Mara River one
thing I've learned in all my years in
the African bush is not to predict too
much like let's wait and see what
happens now of course the gathering of
full of Eastern zebra around the
crossings like this might attract the
attention of the paradise pride of lions
that are loved to hang around at the
crossings and pick off wounded or weak
of all the beasts and zebra and topi for
that matter before their or before or
after they cross the Mara River
yeah
it's all quite a pretty sight there of
all the beasts and zebra mixed I'd say
there's probably a few more wildebeest
and zebra but not too many more
now it's quite uncommon for them to
cross in the dark normally you get some
crossings very early in the morning and
quite a few during the day and then in
the next sort of half an hour is the
last sort of crossing time there looks
to be some zebras that are approaching
the river with a little bit more intent
and I use the brave zebra who will lead
the mass it looks like the Valda beasts
have decided they're not going to follow
the zebra
sure the crocodiles can't wait and they
say it's been tough for the Crocs at the
northern crossings this yet or we
continue to play the patience game here
at Maine south crossing they'd send you
back to James Henry who's still with
those male lions munching on a walk back
yes they are munching away and they've
actually got quite a lot to eat I think
school
and so I think there but from what I
understand there was a bit of a
consternation this morning I'm not sure
what time Oh chopper flying ever
it's either doing some kind of guarding
job or game counting job or something
like that all the vultures have taken to
the skies and terror I'm not sure what
they thought they were going to do when
they were in the sky the blood on the
poor go to the poor the one yeah that's
the one anyway it's very good to be in
their company once again and one of the
line this is apparently moving we can't
see her from here we're just gonna wait
and see if she appears and we'll let you
know
we are of course here with other people
from before sook and they've spotted one
of the females moving casada morally
unsure how to answer that question -
Lions come in more than two or three
colors or German sort of red yellow or
blue the musty yellow never seen a blue
or a red one you're probably talking
about leucism or albinism yes you do get
leucistic lions or white lions they look
not quite I'll be no but they they
certainly look a lot blonder than these
ones their manes come in different
colors often in this area black a mane
indicates more dominance more
testosterone these chaps won't have
black Mane's into a little bit later in
their lives but otherwise Lions are
relatively similar colors the ones up in
the Maasai Mara exactly the same colours
as these ones but quite interestingly
they are a slightly different shape
their ears up there are very boxy and
very hairy and I was chatting about this
just in the other day and he reckons
it's because the wooden flows constantly
over there that the hairs have to
protect the lions years after the Maasai
Mara from the wind
while we were on foot this morning we
did get a radio call that there were
some Lions what they thought fighting
around this area and this is what it
turned out to be and while I think that
the initial thought was that the Lions
the males were having a fight you'll
probably find that it was the male's
chasing the females or firs kill
wonderful Jamie Patterson's got some
male lines probably slightly younger
than these ones as far as I understand
but I did understand from her this
morning that they'd been roaring so I
don't really understand why that
happened
and a whole host of antelope off in the
distance and if these boys are planning
a territorial takeover which I think
that they are I think that's what
they're going to have planned I mean
they were roaring this morning and mitad
Lee probably the most half-hearted roar
I have ever heard in my entire life but
they did roar this morning now if
they're aiming to take over this
territory it would be a very productive
place to be they'll have to get moving a
little bit later but they does seem to
be a vacuum that they are slotting into
when it comes to the absence of male
lions around here
however if they were really intent on
the best possible territory then they
would probably be aiming for the banks
of the Mara River because that is where
all the action happens as the Paradise
pride
well knows
there are few things as mesmerizing as
watching a big cat stalking up to
unsuspecting prey and the Paradise Pride
seemed to have it down to an art a group
of topi that were distracted and
distressed at the prospect of crossing
the Mara River had no idea that the
danger was not in front of them but
rapidly closing the distance from behind
the lioness made her break and the herd
scattered most of the topi raced to
safety along the river but one topi
unwittingly went in the wrong direction
straight towards where the rest of the
pride were hidden in the thicket the
topi was surrounded on every side and
its demise seemed inevitable yet somehow
it bounded away unscathed
even the Lions seemed a tad confused
about how on earth they missed that one
honestly to this day I'm still not
entirely sure how the Paradise pride
missed that topi however I think that
the sheer abundance of food has made the
Lions relatively lackluster in their
hunting attempts shame sort of puncture
wound there on his leg hey boy I brought
over no no we can't see it um male lions
when they're very young are always sort
of smooth and uninjured and beautiful
looking and then they get to the stage
aware their face and their bodies tell
the story of the path that their life
has taken them down and these boys have
just a started of that mouthing one of
course got a truly permanent injury with
that missing tail tip but the network of
scars will eventually crisscross across
their entire face say my name boy the
Mane's on these lines are short because
they are young there is a certain
genetic factor depending upon where you
are in Africa that will affect the
growth of the male's Mane's in some
really hot places to the north of where
we are now you'll actually find that
male lions hardly develop Mane's at all
because there are more of a disadvantage
than anything else in that and that's
there's a genetic aspect to that as well
so these boys I would say the youngest
one who is right now got his BIG's right
in the air he's not providing us with a
view of his mane I would say he's not
much older than three years old if that
his Mane is still very very small these
boys are young to have moved and to
start searching for a territory it's
interesting but perhaps they too have
realized there's a vacuum here that they
can capitalise on I think they have I
think that's what their plan is flies
are starting to really bug them all of
their open wounds the Flies are sitting
on them after all the rain that we've
ah the plan from here I did say to
Monday at halfway the halfway mark we
were gonna go and check on waffles and
just see if she's come across to the den
we'll do a quick loop see if we can find
her she might have gone back to the rest
of the clan rather see if we can find
her if we can't then we will a returner
to these gentlemen who should be getting
up as if the Sun starts to go down as
the likelihood of these lions getting up
it grows ever greater as the Sun Goes
Down the likelihood of those zebra
crossing in the window period if they
have is rapidly closing well their zebra
and wildebeest have spread out now some
of them moving away from the river some
of them just having a grazed I think
there's a chance of a potential crossing
and I think we and I have to pay the
patients game a little longer
unfortunately for us in not too long
we're going to be the only people out in
the whare so if it does happen we'll be
right here
and as we know with nature it is always
a patience game zebras
so nasty to each other
hello ivy Ivy would like to know are
there any predators that go after the
crocodiles when a crocodiles at this
size Ivy very little will go after it
and the Lions will occasionally fight
with them and lions will eat small
crocodiles if the opportunity arises so
will methods but the biggest threat to a
big crocodile is an even bigger
crocodile so they can injure and kill
each other quite frequently and a big
male crocodile like this one sitting
right next to us
he would often eat smaller crocodiles
straight-ahead arch now that is very
unusual they almost never cross in that
position I've never seen a crossing at
that spot I'm just going to move forward
a bit
I know croc gave them a fright so idiots
over a croc jumped up and moved and gave
them a fright here we go
there's there's their croc those Crocs
gave them a fright they nearly stood on
the crocodiles head that was a very
short-lived
but it did get rid of half of the cars
that were surrounding us that Volta
beast nearly stood on that crocodile
selig knew now that might be it for the
evening that might be enough of a scare
that there might not cross the zebras
seem to have decided that they're not
going to cross there's the clock that
nearly got walloped by of all the beasts
on the head that was quite funny but now
you can see the Zebras and the baldies
streaming away from the river
for now all the beasts being bulled the
beasts they could change their mind in
the split-second
it is quite pretty though in this lovely
diffused hate evening light I don't know
I've still got a feeling I think we're
gonna play our patience game a little
bit longer but while we do that they'd
send you back to South Africa to James
and your vocals well I'm very glad the
friend has a feeling something's going
to happen there with his crossing of
course it is one of the most exciting
things you can see in the wild Ernest a
crossing of the great Mara River
crocodiles snapping canoes canoeing
zebras gang as they attempt this swim I
can't imagine a more terrifying gauntlet
in all the world and apparently that
particular crossing being ruined by yet
another intellectually challenged
crocodile I've come to the conclusion
that their existence over the millenia
has got nothing to do with their
intelligence and much to do with the
fact that they are able to hide in the
water and other animals seem to forget
that they are there because a number of
crossings I've seen ruined by an
over-enthusiastic crocodile probably
more than the number of crossings I've
seen so the Avoca males are still
feeding or one of them is one of them
has become recumbent to the right and a
another one well just lifted this head a
little bit further to the right of that
I'm not sure if we can see him since or
can you even see him his neighbors just
sticking out from behind that Bush
there we are wonderful short muslin I
have no idea how the sticks are reacting
to their vocals I think that you'll find
that the sticks pride for the moment is
going to stick well within the ambit of
the Birmingham boys and that is because
they have got much younger Cubs much
younger ones in their pride and if the
focus were to get hold of them I think
they're do some serious damage I think
you'll find the sticks are gonna stick a
long way to the south of their range for
quite some time yet beastly wouldn't
coming up real chill on it this is not
unusual for some timber we get these
fronts moving in and in fact this
particular front it has been a very
severe in some parts of the country and
there are photographs coming out of
elephants walking about in the snow and
that seems to be in the Eastern Cape so
it is a very severe front coming through
here now I'm going to put it to you our
wonderful viewers obviously it's been a
leopard week and we've had a loss of
leopard highlight would you like me to
remain with these Lions for the next
hour of this 14th episode of our lives
or would you like me to go and try and
find a leopard there are no guarantees
nobody has found a leopard today and
nobody did find one this morning so it's
really able to you I'm more than happy
to sit here I'm more than happy to go
and look for a leopard if you would like
me to hash tags for life or use a chat
stream on YouTube
sins was just saying that he's can see a
birds but he's not sure if it's the same
as all the others beautifully spotted
sins are your eyes are really quite
special
it's a tawny eagle beautifully spotted
so the to legal as we often say is a
scavenger and here it is sitting in
amongst the less fancied vultures
thinking to itself hearted I find myself
amongst this sort of ancillary scum
Pinilla nice all right while you're
voting Jamie has left her Lions and I'm
gonna bet you a million dollars that
she's on the way to find waffles and
waffles as Cubs that waffles is dead
well I don't know if I can find where I
want to go I'm trying to find waffles
but I can't drive off-road unless I see
her I can't simply take myself off and
drive back to where I think I left her
because I actually to be honest I have
no idea where she might be so I'm going
past some of the old den sites looking
to see back and spot her she could
easily be resting up in the shade or she
might have decided to wait out the lion
invasion and has gone to go spend some
time with the rest of her clan which
were over the side this morning
at the end of the morning Safari we came
this way and we discovered it vultures
on a carcass and some very fat hyenas
around so that's where they will be
they'll be around here and she might be
with them I'm hoping that's the case but
what I'm really hoping for obviously
without any risk to our waffles as
little Cubs is that she brings them out
for us so that we can show them to you
those of you who've been watching over
the course of the week will know they
are utterly adorable utterly charming
and they're starting to spend a lot more
time out of their den
the day we had been waiting for from the
moment we discovered waffles as Cubs had
finally arrived at five weeks old the
waffle 'its were full of youthful energy
and kept themselves occupied by climbing
their mother wrestling each other or
wrestling each other while climbing
their mother wrinkled and completely
uncoordinated they are already starting
to show distinctive personalities the
tatty eared cub is the boulder of the
two and it was quite happy to wander off
as long-suffering waffles trailed behind
to make sure it was safe the rounded cub
clearly the more dominant is actually
more reserved and was reluctant to leave
the safety of the den entrance it dashed
between the two holes before looking
around for mum anxiety written all over
its tiny face eventually the absence of
waffles and its sibling coaxed her back
out into the open to join them a hyena
den visit wouldn't be complete without a
game of tug of war and the tatty eared
cub kindly obliged us with a
demonstration on a stick waffles
an experienced and loving mother rounded
off a wonderful morning by flopping down
on one of her cubs finished it off with
waffles and giving us an astounding
demonstration of her mothering skills
there now hyena Cubs are built tough
that's what they have to be it's a tough
world they're entering into and there's
lots of competition from other clan
mates so they have to be as tough as
they can be from the earliest age oh
it's not just was having babies I'm just
gonna stop here these warthogs I've seen
one or two tiny little piglets wandering
around he definitely won't have piglets
because he's a boy that is a male water
ability
I haven't seen any around the side it's
odd the birth seem to be really
localized around certain areas as I
first saw piglets about three four weeks
ago away from here no definitely not
no little piggies there the topi have
also started giving birth there's quite
a few of them around North clan's
territory in fact this is the most Valle
de beast and topi I've seen in North
clans territory since the start of the
migration lots and lots of food around
for them here all they'll need to do is
wait until they bunch up together at
night and then race into the middle of
them just as Ferg was doing last week
and trying to catch one any baby totally
no baby topi let's continue our circuit
round I'm gonna just go back around to
where our last saw waffles
and see if we can find her
I'm really hoping it's my last night in
the Mara it's just sheer stubbornness at
this point James is far less stubborn
than I am he puts something to a vote
let's go and find out what the answer
was I'm not sure that aren't farlis
stubborn but anyway we are still here
and apparently the vote is in and the
answer is seventy-five percent of you
want to stay with the lions and
twenty-five percent of you say Lions
suck and you'd rather go and see some
lipids well sorry for you
we're going to stay with the Lions you
didn't really say that of course you
just like to see some lipids I like to
see lipids all the time but I'm very
interested to see these Lions as well
now what was very interesting there is
that he looks pretty skinny and in fact
the muscle tone on his back end really
didn't look very good at all so I don't
know where these guys have been since we
last saw them well I mean I know they'd
been up north that I've all I've been
doing there he doesn't look like he's in
the best condition to his life maybe
things have been a little bit more
difficult then we think they have for
the Avoca males
it's looking ponderously up towards the
north the lionesses haven't moved since
we last saw them so I don't think
they're going to come down here I think
rather like the vultures they're sitting
here in Hope waiting for these lands
perhaps to go off and have a drink
there's a waterhole not too far from
here wait for them to go and have a
drink before they sneak in steal a bit
to eat and then come back alright well
we'll stay with the Lions for another
segment or two brent Leo Smith
apparently is with a very sad-looking
Striped Pyjamas Anki I don't know why it
should be sad but I'm sure he'll tell us
okay well we come to check on the
wounded zebra and no signs of north clan
or any Lions just yet but that doesn't
mean they're going not going to arrive
so I think we're gonna hang around yet
it's managed to sit down it's moved
about ten meters since we first saw it
and we're at that time of the evening
when the Predators will start patrolling
oh look what's already on its way
there's a little black back jackal so
directly in front of me now the Zebras
might not be wounded enough for the in
jackal to take it down but it might
definitely pester that zebra now Trish
is asking why don't they help the zebra
I thought they helped all the wounded
animals in the Mara and certain animal
species Trish and lions leopard elephant
and most of the time well with the
species that are not lions it is only if
it is a human injury this injury is
definitely from a crocodile and humans
had nothing to do with it it's part of
nature's cycle so the Predators will
feast I mean interesting see what this
little jackal does now and she just put
its head down completely so it's lying
flat so that little jackal might
approach it like it's a caucus and might
get a big surprise we might see a flying
jackal I have seen that before
and the jackal stop to be cautious or is
it just behind some grass on grass and
still moving
Ida's Everett lifted its head and at the
jackal being a little bit more cautious
yes taking a slightly wider berth and
it'll be hoping for the North Klan or
paradise pride to find the zebra and
then can then feed off the scraps
so there is the injured zebra lifted its
head now and sometimes nature can be
quite quite gruesome to watch
but if you think I've got patience pants
and can sit it out waiting for something
to happen
I've got nothing on a Jacqueline ena
like how that as ever his ears have gone
completely flat so any of you have
horses at home or spent much time with
horses it's a sign of distress or anger
when ears go flat like that so even the
presence of a predator as small as a
jackal is enough to cause that Zebras
ears to go flat
I'm just keeping scanning around trying
to see where or if there are any other
large predators about
I know a lot of you are feeling quite
sorry for the zebra but just think about
the little jackal in the meal he's going
to get out of this once the other bigger
predators arrive everything is connected
unfortunately for the zebra it's time
for it to recycle its nutrients back
into the ecosystem heads still up there
jackal knows if it gets too close get a
big kick while we continue our vigil
this time not for zebras crossing but
for a wounded zebra waiting for a
predator to arrive
this is what we call a pram ball a prey
gamble while we wait around for
something to happen in the meantime
let's send you across to Jamie who's on
the move vigil we are we back again I
forgot there's no such thing as a short
loop in the Mara so I've done a little
reverse back on myself along the road
where we last saw waffles
nothing to be honest so there's the
Daintree the Ballon I tease forgot I
promised I'd shared hugga tree
completely forgot over I can't hug that
when it's right next to the den listen
just caught the tail end of a loop
sounds like a young loop not a cub
though maybe one of the older ones but
from that direction I think it's
interesting could also of course be
happy zebra because the North clans den
is surprisingly close to there but their
boundary it's here at Oriel boundary
excuse me just a little bit far to be
next to Awful's is den beautiful sunset
but it's already very very chilly with
temperatures dropping rapidly
if we don't have any luck we're not
gonna sit out beside her den just in
case for some reason discourages her
from returning not that it ever has in
the past but the Lyons there I think
we'll probably be rather go back to the
Lions and keep alternating between the
two we're nearly there
I left her somewhere here she should
have taken clothes and I should actually
have GPS where I was because she hyena
can vanish --tz-- phenomenal how a hyena
can disappear into this ecosystem they
find themselves a deep muddy hole and
they go and hide there in long grass and
it's impossible to find them again I
think just yeah I think I came out the
side
that's good a little bit quicker
okay we're gonna go around the corner
fingers crossed waffles is there while
we do that James who also fortunately
for us has his patients pants on is
still with the Evo cos I do not have my
patients pants on earth with my
celebratory weekend depends on which
I've shown you many times of course
before I think they're very very fancy
indeed I wear them for the kids show and
for Safari lights I also wouldn't pull a
TV shows now everything's quiet and down
here sea lions are doing what Lions do
best which of course it's absolutely
nothing there they are doing absolutely
nothing
none of them does its head very briefly
and then put it down again and so while
we enjoy these Lions as I said at the
beginning it has been a rather lifted
filled week and young Isana aged 2.5
years has been trying out various
hunting techniques husana had a hungry
time of it this week his last big meal
being the Pittsville parlour he spelled
Tandy
he never looks thin say must be eating
small things frequently squirrels and
scrub hairs is most likely victims the
little chief spent a lot of time
experimenting with various hunting
techniques often during daylight hours
he focused on two main areas tree house
waterhole and the gallagher pan near
camp these obviously provide water but
also ample opportunity for ambush
spending so much time with a hunting cat
shows again and again how difficult it
is for the Predators out here to catch a
decent meal and then keep it for
themselves so that was with Hama on the
hunt he didn't catch a water buck like
this although in theory one day he might
be able to I suppose probably always be
slightly too big for him but I think
that perfect I were discussing it
earlier today as we walked past a tree
in which we'd seen him eating a fully
grown Impala but before he disappeared
the first time so you know good six
seven months ago and I have to ask
myself why it is that he isn't either a
succeeding in catching big play like
that now or be not trying to catch big
prey like that is it because he's
getting enough in the way of squirrels
and scrub hares and small things or has
he lost his confidence perhaps in some
way is it just that he's going through a
phase I don't know but it has been a
while since we've seen him kill
something that size I don't think
there's necessarily anything wrong I
just think it's quite interesting that
for the last little while the only
things we've seen him eating squirrels
and scrub hares and then there was the
duiker that we heard that he was feeding
on yesterday morning but that was most
likely killed by tündi we think unless
she joined him there to kill that he had
made and Herbert was also saying to me
earlier today that he had seen that
before he'd seen sisters older sisters
going to fetch younger brothers and
the brothers going to fix older sisters
to their kills know whether that's
happened here or not of it
I doubt it has but the leopard dynamics
certainly are very interesting and I'm
just fascinated by while Sanne is not
killing bigger prey I think it's normal
for any predator during the dry season
to concentrate their activities around
water holes
that's because obviously the prey that
they like to eat has to come down and
drink in here and in the case of things
like Nepal or Buffalo they must drink
often twice a day towards the real
business end of the dry season and so it
is not uncommon to find him feeding or
trying to feed around water holes the
one thing are completely and utterly
forgot to do today is go to see scoobert
the scoobert are young little Lapwing is
still alive and I completely forgot now
I think that if these Lions do not get
up and do something in the next five
minutes I'm going to go down and see
scoobert see if we can't find her solid
lurking around the same place the
lionesses are not going to come here
while the male's here I don't think the
males are going to go anywhere until
they have finished this kill so let's go
back across Julia Smith who apparently
has put his patience pants and down and
he's now driving around the place now
we're gonna head off and see if we can't
find scoobert and delivered him well
we've left our tramble because
fortunately our friends from Michigan
State University hyena research project
are gonna watch that zebra for us so we
can wander around a little bit but the
sky is on fire this evening look at that
sunset isn't that absolutely spectacular
magical
oh man Namara skies are tough to beat
just so peaceful if you just quiet and
listen for a second
of course then we hear a car and some
people making some noise
if he's dull
now while the Sun continues to set we're
gonna send you to almost directly below
where that Sun is setting to see what
the Ala la la pride has been up to
next the ah la la la pride have become
set in the sausage tree pride lands
vocalizing and making their presence
known these lands are rich with the
bounty of the migration unlike the north
of the triangle where they have moved
from with so much food around the
hunting has been almost haphazard with
the migrating herds surrounding them
they seem confident of a kill
when rather than it
they continue to peruse the herds for
any signs of weakness after dark one
lioness and tempted a little more
seriously
but unfortunately missed after failure
they settled down for an
sorry guys sorry I did wrong
oh my gosh what are you doing so we had
a flat tire this morning and Archie put
the tire back on the space side and I
said to you you wanted tighten that
those bolts with the wheel space it's
fine I was fitting that side now all of
a sudden I turn around I see Archie
hanging off the car with the wheel
Spanish trying to tighten the the spare
tire as we're moving sorry and I I for
some reason I thought I thought that was
one of the funniest things I've seen in
a long time but I'm gonna swing around
now again I heard some guinea fowl
alarming I just wanted to come check and
so you can have a look at that sunset
again and I can and while you do that
wait before we do that in front of this
big tree we'll just dropped its head
whatever it was so they're down on the
guide to Tommy I thought I'd spotted
something interesting there there's
wildebeest and zebra on the other side
but let's quickly go across to that
gorgeous ball of fire and that supplies
light and life to our little world
those Suns about halfway through its
life cycle on average lasts about 10
billion years and halfway through its
life cycle listen but while we watch the
sunset we're gonna send you James who's
got something better than a sunset and
that's Lions in golden light
we do indeed have a lion in the light
and since always decided that he's going
to be very artistic this afternoon we
were pulling out of the sighting and he
eventually said well can't you just
drive down there and then put the Sun
behind the lion so I said oh all right
and look at that very pretty shot of an
uncle who my lion is backlit by the
Setting Sun here in the Western cougar
National Park very nice I don't think
that this is amber eyes and the youngest
lioness so I'm really not sure which two
these are David you were asking if the
uncle who has moved off yes most of them
did but we've got to watching their kill
with her well shall we say hungry eyes
perhaps eyeing up the boys thinking to
themselves them is quite young but a
good looking nevertheless you can see
how if you were approaching a potential
piece of prey doing it into the Sun
would be a very good way of getting
there without being seen at least with
the Sun behind you not into the Sun
and whew you hear that wind blowing and
I can tell you that it feels very cold
despite the warmth of this picture and
that's perfectly normal this time of
year these fronts do come through I'll
tell you what for something to have the
in Co Huma lionesses up like this when
they could be asleep they must be pretty
hungry
Craig all lions roars sound different to
two lions so they're able to recognize
individual lands from their rules the
ones up in the Mara not to my ears no
they sound very similar to the ones here
male and female do sound slightly
different males call for longer their
individual rules tend to sound slightly
longer and probably slightly louder but
I wouldn't say that I've noticed a
difference between the rules in the Mara
and those here in the sabi sands here we
go the sun's just gone down enough now
to make this a really interesting
picture beautiful sins or do you feel
like an artiste right now I will just
tell you as sins or shoots the beautiful
golden light pouring on to the Inca home
a private not only is he being artistic
right now he's dressed in a quite
astonishing array of enormous white
bhava boots blue socks with mustaches on
them green jacket and he's put his
dreadlocks up into a side bun is really
a picture to be seen
the last time I saw a side button I
think was on the TV sitcom Three's
Company I'm not sure if you remembered
but the sideburn is back now isn't that
gorgeous
all right now I believe we are going to
have another look at some lipids this
time they're going to be non-live and
they are this time going to be they are
it is going to be one lipid and this
time she rather longingly was looking
for her daughter quite like these lions
longingly looking at their meat Tandy
and Columbus tracks had frustrated us
all of Tuesday morning around about
treehouse dam the boiling afternoon had
the Queen resting on a termite mound
before sitting off on a lengthy quest to
find her daughter she smelt cold and
chuffed to no avail there is something
deeply disquieting about watching a
mother looking for her baby without
success
fear for the beloved cub began to build
as the hot silent afternoon wore on and
tandi's efforts continued to burn no
fruit
eventually the sunset the Queen gave up
and we were left unsettled as darkness
fell thankfully although we didn't see
it the pair was reunited during the
night now many of you were very
unsettled and worried after that
sighting the tracks did indicate that
remember and Tandy met up that evening
and in the morning after that when we
were on foot with the Inca Hummers or we
did find Columba and then we've seen
their track subsequent to that as well
so she's absolutely fine but more and
more Tandy is having to look for her and
that evening or the evening after Tandy
at least a brief entre lumba he found
Tandy again and she once more was
calling for her daughter number being
recalcitrant very rebellious not coming
when called right well that was gorgeous
we're gonna go across to Jaime now with
waffle ease surprise surprise I was
looking for waffle ease actually we're
gonna go and see if we can get a quick
view of scoobert before the Sun Goes
Down I'm really sorry I know James has
got into the habit of linking with what
linking to me with waffles and trust me
I wish I was with waffles I really
really do instead we have a glorious
sunset to show you complete with rain
over the escarpment and two male lions
who are however unintentionally
responsible for the lack of said waffles
I'm going to have to beg whoever is left
behind tomorrow to go straight to
waffles as day the first thing in the
morning because I have to tell you it
stinks the den stinks
not that I'm leaving stinks the Dame
stinks and it doesn't stink like hyena
it smells like like rotten meat and I'm
hoping it's because these two boys
actually killed something close to the
den last night and they finished eating
it and they've lifted
that's what I'm hoping because it really
really smells bad I've driven past at
three times trying to decide that I'm
imagining it and we're not imagining it
so we'll have to get people to go first
thing tomorrow to go and ascertain the
status of waffles as the bull waffle is
I'm sure they find in these two boys I
was hoping we're going to roll perhaps
give us a demonstration into the Mara
lion roaring versus Juma lion roaring
and there's still the possibility that
they could of course is still owned your
son has only just said now they'll be
getting up shorty they've got up and
moved from where they were underneath
the tree Sparra you say that we win the
sunset we just happened to be there at
the right time to be honest although I
don't suppose it's really me so much as
money who wins the sunset although we're
all winners here aren't we money they're
all winners when we get to watch a
sunset like this that as Jerry would say
would look it looks a little bit like it
was painted by someone it almost seems
impossible that something could be that
beautiful is she with a Balon I t's tree
so so conveniently placed and shaped my
goodness the excitement
yeah and a big yawn of course as you
know with our big cats yawning like that
grooming their feet
yawning repeatedly again is a sign that
they are perhaps contemplating getting
up in this case it seems as though yawn
one of them is a very loud breather very
loud w James I see absolutely no reason
why a Juma lion wouldn't survive in
tomorrow got another yawn I I wonder if
perhaps a better question would be would
a group of Juma lions survive in the
Mara because of course a lion on its own
whether it's a male or females is that's
distinct disadvantage their social cats
they need companionship okay a young
male lion here in the Mara from Juma
would probably find itself a companion
or two or three but you couldn't really
translocate a female here and expect her
to thrive on her own but yes I see no
reason why I lion from Juma it would
take them some time to adapt but
personally I think they could adapt
quite quickly it's different hunting
conditions open plains rather than the
slight or the very thick in places
woodland of Juma and just change their
hunting techniques just in the same way
the Lions here do when the grass is
short versus when it's long scraggly
little mane and the beginnings of a
mohawk
it is the time of nights when most of
the big predators out here are waking
from their day's slumber which is great
news for us is not fantastic news for
that poor zebra
yes and same so for sensitive use you
can see now how actually how bad this
wound actually is as ever just try to
move and it fell down shame poor zebra
hasn't stopped it eating though there's
a very small chance that it might
survive so it's got to keep it strength
up but I would not bet on it
I think it's just been very very lucky
that a large predator hasn't discovered
it yet the Jackals are still wandering
around not too far from it see the
Jackals there arch that tree is in the
Setting Sun almost directly straight
down from there but close to us and a
little bit to the left
it's just moved a bit to the left down a
bit there it is and as I said jackals
have serious serious a serious set of
patients pants
waiting for the possibility of another
large predator to find and that poor
unfortunate zebra
I think we're gonna gamble here a little
bit longer to see what happens we spent
quite a bit of time this week with the
oh la la la pride and finally we caught
up with them after they had some success
finally we find the 300 log lionesses
having made a successful kill early in
the morning judging from their fat
bellies this wasn't their first kill of
the night but rather their last their
behavior was playful and jovial as one
female conducted the serious business of
moving the carcass to a suitable area
while the others harassed her in a
playful manner but it didn't take too
long for them to settle down and feed
off the poor young filled the Beast is
that poor unfortunate Deborah still
there no sign of the north clan just yet
of any lions and a lip at zebra in that
state would even be fair game for a male
leopard and I have seen a big male
leopard around here
shame poor little thing well that's a
little bit poor thing
Brenda is wondering would vultures find
this zebra um possibly not just yet they
are not really gonna go for something
that server is still completely capable
of defending itself against vultures
jackal and smaller predators it have to
be one of the larger predators I in a
leopard or line and to take it down and
then once the carcass was on the ground
I'm sure the vultures would find it but
I don't think the vultures would hang
around with an animal that's still that
lively even I think that zebra even with
a group of hyenas one or two owners
would still give a very good account of
itself in defending itself but I think
the end would be inevitable it suddenly
just got quite a bit darker when the
skies are still absolutely gorgeous
tonight and the rain has stayed away yay
this time last night Archie and I were
battering down the hatches we were
getting absolutely pummeled by a massive
storm
shame poor zebra okay well I'm gonna
wait it out a little bit longer and when
we do that I'd send you across to James
I am looking for a livid I'm also going
to try and see if I can't find
scoobert we'll go down into the dam
itself because the pan next to the dam
where scoobert and his parents have
spent most of the day is now occupied by
Conrad the engineer who is currently
fixing something I'm not sure what
exactly so while we go down here
the third leopard that we saw this week
earliest this week was ten Ghana and I
was most pleased to hear that he seemed
to have killed something on his own and
he had a very unusual visitor to the
queue for the first time in a long while
Kangana seemed to have killed something
himself rather than pilfering from a
hard-working predator his victim was a
Nala cow that the killed attracted a
scavenger an unusual one it's been a hot
week out here and heat can cause tempers
to fray more quickly than they might
otherwise the Duke not known for his
willingness to share was scandalized by
the cheeky slender Mongoose which he
eventually put to flight the little
carnivore was the least of his worries
however hyenas pinched the rest of his
meal during the night sins or scans to
see if we can see the little fella there
is his parent let's just have a quick
discussion on ting gana we have not seen
him since that kill so I think he's
probably been resting he doesn't like to
extend himself too much but these days
of course he is moving a little bit more
than he has been
for the past few months so maybe just
maybe he's off marking territory
somewhere
scoobert have you been put to bed
already there is I've got him
he's he's running towards the parent
[Laughter]
hello Scoob he's such a cute little
thing no it's hiding there he comes
put his head up so we introduce you to
scoobert last week the zoomies on the
dam cam have been doing a sterling job
of following his progress during the
course of the last seven days and i
meant to start today with him and then i
forgotten the excitement of going to see
the Avoca boys but I'm so pleased we've
got the second Safari lives episode that
features scoobert the blacksmith Lapwing
everybody is very pleased to see
scoobert the blacksmith Lapwing running
after his parent here comes the other
parent now he's so sweet
it would be extremely difficult for me I
must confess were a predator to come in
here and try and have a go at scoobert
it would be very difficult and extremely
possibly impossible for me to just sit
here and watch him be devoured I think I
would have to I will be unable to stop
myself interfering Scoob don't go in
there there might be snakes there you
are don't come out
follow your mom or your dad now for
those of you who haven't been watching I
have been reciting a few statistics
about the success chances that young
scoobert has and they are not good
extensive
has been conducted on the blacksmith
Lapwing and only some 26% of them fledge
fledging takes 40 days and by my
reckoning scoobert is now around about
14 days old I think he might be slightly
older than that maybe 21 so he's got
another three weeks or so to go before
he's able to fly and once he can fly of
course his chances of survival of that
much greater but until then he must rely
on his exceptional camouflage which I
suppose will get less and less effective
as he gets bigger and bigger he's really
much larger than he was last week he's
much faster than he was last week too oh
he's just too delightful no funky
hampster nobody could see that to see
scoobert die would be just to deal too
much I feel
he's so sweet such a I suppose it's real
jeopardy having a little guy like this
and knowing that he's got to get to 40
days before he can fly oh there we are
yes little bit cold and our mum's gonna
look after him just warm him up so many
hearts melting in the file control and
possibly not only there since it we get
him the Fleur or not the too far just
gonna try and see if we can catch him in
the thermal camera scenic a little thing
like this would be preyed upon by
Raptors so the Wahlberg's Eagle would
definitely have a go at him the water
monitor lizards that are around here
snakes that are around here civets
Janet's African Wildcats white tailed
Mongoose anything wandering about here
at nighttime that likes to eat meat
would have a go at him
we can't find him in the Fleur at the
moment yes well I would quite like to be
under the wing of that bird as well
because the wind is very cold indeed
we'll try and find Scooby with the
thermal camera and while we do that
let's go back across to the Masai Mara
where Jane Lee Patterson is with some
sleeping Leone's
well James attempts to find a scoobert
with the yeah we have our lines
stretching and rolling over some new
gentlemen who have only just had the
chance to meet who perhaps will cause
chaos over the next few months who knows
we will just have to wait and see as I
said these are new boys for me I've
never encountered them before but I'm
really glad that I had the opportunity
to catch up with the sausage tree pride
one last time catching up with old
friends is one of the simplest and most
fulfilling pleasures that life has to
offer
seeing the sausage tree pride again had
a very similar feeling for me but as
often happens in busy lives we had lots
to catch up on there boys have moved on
choosing to stay with Cooley in his
conquest further south and two of the
females were missing from the remaining
pride kinky tails wound while certainly
painful was looking pink and clean and
will no doubt be healed in a few short
weeks their new hangout has been filled
with wildebeest and zebra since the
migration arrived in the Triangle no
doubt this is why they chose to be here
the females were full and content and
made no efforts to disguise their
presence a few zebra appeared myopically
in their direction creeping closer and
snorting as though to make absolutely
certain that they were indeed lions a
sensible tactic it's never the lying you
see that gets you however in this case
the Lions were content to indulge in a
rare moment of peace a peaceful moment
for the sausage tree pride and I look
forward to hearing about the tales of
their adventures particularly of course
the tales of kinky tales adventures I
couldn't resist we're going to check one
last time I've left our Lions they're
still very sleepy so for the last few
minutes of this episode I thought maybe
just maybe we'll get lucky I'm crossing
fingers holding thumbs every bush looks
like a hyena that really looks like ie
no but I think it's just no it's waffles
it's waffles is it it is it's a whole
load of anus who are you it's not
waffles
bristle tailed hello
it's not waffles it's one of the coves
I'm just gonna do a quick spotlight is
that waffle over there it is it's
waffles I'm just gonna take the light
off her for a second let's go a little
bit closer hello girl you timed that
very well very very well she's sniffing
around the den yeah well done woof big W
that's smell
she doesn't look concerned she doesn't
look concerned at all oh now we're
racing weight from here office you can't
do this to me you can't disappear now
she doesn't look concerned at all which
makes me think that whatever that smell
is it's nothing too serious it's nothing
to worry about
oh sorry whoever you are don't mean to
rush you but we'd all like for me to say
goodbye it's waffles we wouldn't mind
moving your little bottom no okay that's
all right I'll just do this
and cut the corner instead
no it's fine if waffles is behaving like
this the way she is she's behaving very
dominantly they're racing for some
reason but there's no anxiety which
comes as a massive relief to me because
I was full of anxiety I don't know what
it is that smells like that at the den
but it's nothing too serious where we
going waffles it's a problem with
following hyenas sorry who have you arm
cutting you off for a second I'm just
gonna switch around I promise I won't be
long
where we going waffles your tail up its
how I'll always think of a oh oh
social snip social snip it's for my
favorite things to watch waffle smells
something interesting in whoever she's
with goes oh I like that smell - look
see we've got something in common
I like that smell a lot
so as it turns out last few moments with
waffles are not going to be spent with
her being a gentle mother but as the
leader of her clan directing them you
know whichever way they should go thank
you
someone else is coming to join the
social sniff
it's your turn - oh yes here we go
there's the smell are you interested
come on you gotta show waffles that you
like that smell it's a bonding
experience
James Richard you say how magical for
one last sighting absolutely I couldn't
of sitting looking at those lions as
Kirsty was counting down our our clip
and thinking I can't I can't sit here
and not see her one last time I just had
to take a chance she probably came out
in the middle of the day and fed those
Cubs she knows what she's doing
thank you off we go we're embracing off
it's my way home anyway I'm gonna follow
her one last time
race to the clan one last time for now I
mean obviously
off we go for high years in front of me
probably more coming behind me into the
night
with my squeaky car squeak squeak squeak
squeak
oh yes indeed the hyenas are going to go
towards that injured zebra and
unfortunately I believe they will be the
ones to put it out of their misery
they're already racing in that direction
they're quite far but that's where
they're going and once again north clan
will capitalize and do the dirty work
that the Mara River has started all
right I'm not gonna get you one last
view of waffles unfortunately because
somebody in front of me is is taking
taking its time trotting along the road
not quite keeping up or worth of the
matriarch so that brings us to the end
of our this episode of safari lives I
hope you have enjoyed yourselves and
glad that you could join us thank you so
much as always it's your questions and
comments and sharing it with you that
makes it all the more special